in New York City they have a great they
have one great rule about Central Park
7:00 to 9:00 in the morning off the
leash for a dog my dog runs every
morning we're out there around quarter
7:00 we run for about half hour 45 I
don't run I walk on the golf course I
don't use carts if I that's good but
that is fun watching your dog run in the
dewy grass and the meowing just like and
they're all kind of rollover when I
figured out how he not to have him
attack other dogs since he's a retriever
he's a golden retriever I put a ball in
his mouth and he won't let go of the
ball so he can't bite anybody runs
throughout the park with a boy he's not
gonna he's not gonna let go and I go to
the ball he may bark you know muffled
bark but that's it
[Music]
so why didn't you shows last you know
then so many different reasons just like
internal things and then also you get
what did you work for if you said about
Comedy Central who I now work for on the
radio and then MTV so they didn't play
it enough it wasn't on I wanted to do I
want to do a show if I ever do a talk
show again it cannot be one time a week
if they don't replay it the audience
doesn't get to know yeah yeah you can
trust you
you can't gather an audience once a week
you don't have the time to and look
unless you're some variety show and I'm
not you see it's very interesting for
instance in daytime they've tried so
many actors comedians people who were
never ever broadcasters as talk show
hosts it doesn't work yeah just I'm very
interested for instance next year Kelly
Clarkson is going to do a talk show and
so it's going to be interesting as to
whether that works
Ellen works Alan were Rosie O'Donnell
worked for a while for a while I loved
sheep but then she got she got dark you
know what I mean yes yes yes it went it
went yeah I got a little weird at the
end that was a fun one but it is these
things coming I mean you must see them
come and go all the time can you tell
when something's gonna work what what
what's for instance I mean there there
are a lot of person I knew Shane Pauly
wouldn't work well I knew Meredith
Vieira wouldn't work what well first of
all you have to understand these were
people who made their mark and made
their reputations in in in shows that
were an ensemble the Today Show is an
ensemble no I'm telling hey Matt Lauer
right biggest name in the world not
they're still Today Show works you know
bring on the next person plug them in
it's an ensemble right you go alone
without someone and it yes okay you go
alone you're you've got to be a
different person than you were when you
were that ensemble and so
it just doesn't work that way yeah
doesn't work that they didn't develop
that skill as a solo host or the
audience isn't going to want to see them
in that role I guess I mean you never
you never know how far you can get that
way unless you do something solo yeah
you gotta try you got to do something
solo before before you know you're gonna
work I mean and it took me along first
of all I mean look I'm a news guy I
never got along with my co-anchors ever
really I mean look and years ago I was
the second banana to a woman named
Connie Chung at the big station in LA
and guess what they fired me she uh I
started before her I'm much older than
she about much I'm significantly older
and so I was a pretty big name in
Washington DC my hometown she was hired
as the assistant to the news director
the secretary okay the first job that
opens up in a newsroom is a weekend
writing job she wants the job the news
director says you can't have the job
you're my assistant you're my secretary
hey Kim yes I want the job well you
can't get the job unless you replace
yourself she walks out of the newsroom
across the street into a bank looks at
the first woman teller and says you want
to be in TV come with me replaced
herself and became a big star I asked
force and nobody really knew who she was
and then all of a sudden we're going wow
that took a lot of guts I mean that's
really aggressive and so she becomes a
star she goes to LA she becomes the big
and a big anchor and then I'm hired as
her second banana her co-anchor that
didn't work and six months later the new
general manager fired me and then so she
took such pity on me we started to date
[Laughter]
no I mean no I just no maybe
well Connie she had become a pretty big
star at CBS in the Washington bureau
during Watergate I mean she was the big
star during Watergate and so she went to
LA and became a you know a huge hit and
she really did and I was she was the
only person I knew in that whole West
Coast newsroom and so when I got fired
she took pity on me well how did that
feel I mean you getting fired was the
worst thing in my life the best thing
the best thing because yes the greatest
fear of anyone in this business is
getting fired that's the worst fear
because a you don't know what its gonna
feel like and B will you ever work again
and so when you end up having the
feeling at least you know what it's like
it's that's so true
I believe that that's all part of my
personality that I bring out hey I've
had my lows you know I've been fired
I've laid down on a couch and wondered
to myself should I be in this business I
mean what the hell oh yeah oh that's
great to hear that you've had that
thought oh yeah yeah no I mean and then
would you do it what you do yeah and
watching TV you know and I'm watching
all the newscast I'm saying I'm as good
as that guy yeah I can do that story
what the heck and so I got a job in San
Francisco about three or four months
later and then we started dating and had
a commuting relationship between LA and
San Francisco but never we've dated for
eight years before we got married
what that's all part but not exclusively
she says I dated people I couldn't even
remember their first names and she dated
nothing but stars in Hollywood yeah so
that's before you got married and
settled down you were together and you
would see each other when you could but
you just there was no in fact she said
she would say to me sometimes well maybe
we should get married and I said no
and then I would say to her well maybe
we should get married she said no I
don't want him and then finally she
called me up and she said we can get
married now I said why she says because
I found a dress later we got married oh
my glass and that was 34 years ago Wow
and then where where did you move after
that what do you got me well then I was
back in Washington and she was in New
York and we commuted for the first two
years and then this wild Australia named
Rupert Murdoch called up and said we're
going to start this show called a
Current Affair and we're gonna move you
to New York and you're gonna find out
whether you can live with your wife now
you have to understand I went I was a I
was a local anchorman so she would we
would I would come to New York every
week or two to see each other on the
weekends were married and I would go to
the apartment building and I would say
Connie Chung please who is this I said I
I'm her husband and he would call up and
say Ms Chung mr. Chung is down that's
when I knew yeah she's she is
indefatigable she's got a look that word
up later yeah she's just good nothing
can penetrate her she is going to do and
to March back to going across the street
and taking a girl from the bank and
saying do you want to be in TV because I
want this job what happened I guard the
bank she's ended up being a talk show
producer for me at that station that's
what happens
that see you now yeah I don't work at a
bank
all you bank tellers out there first of
all do they have bank tellers anymore no
I don't know I do everything on my app
yeah that's true yes anybody ever go
into the bank anymore
very rarely I recently wrote a joke
where I was like and I went to the bank
and I'm like no one's believing this
right you do everything on the app right
you make withdrawals you put your check
in you want to Instagram are you on
Twitter use oh yeah how do you feel
about it do you like it well the show is
on it first of all the show is I mean
we've got like three million Facebook
amazing people and another million
YouTube people and but I I have a hard
time I see a lot of lot of people who I
know who are in the business they're on
Twitter and I wake up in the morning I
usually wake up like 6:00 6:30 to walk
the dog and all of a sudden all these
people are on Twitter I'm like what the
hell you doing this early in the morning
oh yeah just responding to stuff that's
just you know I it's almost like being a
shrink
I think Twitter's become a shrink or let
me tell you what happened to me really
do I really want to know yeah I know
it's it's it's sad sometimes you see
like if someone's going one of your
friends is having like a manic moment
and you're like bro you might want to
pull this back a little bit and then of
course you better not do anything wrong
because somebody's got a phone and it's
on video yeah I mean how is it like for
you out there just our people coming up
to you boring as you know if it's a
guy right can you say Stan you are not
the father Laurie Povich write it down
here that kind of stuff yeah and there
are a lot of selfies I don't mind it
yeah I've always you know I've over the
years I've known personalities who just
don't do that don't sign autographs
don't take pictures and I'm saying hey
man I mean you spend a lot of time
trying to get people to look at you get
into your life and then you just you
know shove them away and don't have
anything to do it so and I take look I'm
on I'm on television five days a week an
hour or two hours a day if they know you
that's the best of the alternative what
happens if they don't know you that
means that you're screwing up and you
ain't making it work yeah yeah the fact
that you're being record
you just taking a few seconds of your
life to sign up that their fan for life
it doesn't matter what you do selfies
always gonna be like I'm tea Maury oh I
love selfies they're quick phone to
someone else you don't to look at it
again you're done yeah that's a that's a
good isn't that something that maybe
you've found since you've been famous
for decades isn't that kind of fun
selfies have changed maybe the getting
recognized made it more expedited that
there used to be the Polaroid it's
really I think it's it's fun yeah I mean
it is I mean it's the new polar stay
right here more
[Laughter]
[Music]
you